good morning and welcome my name is
Sharon Kugler and I'm the Yale
University chaplain it's a true
privilege to assist with this service of
remembrance honoring those among the
first women in Yale College who have
died before they could mark this 50-year
milestone as I visited the extraordinary
exhibit over at the Sterling Memorial
Library last week it was striking to see
how much the first women who came to
Yale to get an education actually
educated Yale what they endured what you
endured and how you became the women
whose remarkable minds and hearts have
touched and improved the world is most
humbling and deeply inspiring the
generations of women that have and will
continue to follow you do not walk in
your shadow they are walking in your
light this morning we have come together
to carve out a little time and space to
nurture our hearts there's much to
celebrate outside of these walls and yet
we are also mindful that our circle a
celebration is incomplete in the midst
of the festivities of this weekend our
hearts also ache there are pieces of us
sisters who are missing
for a little while we will take some
time to pause in loving remembrance for
those who have left this earth and are
not here to share in the many facets of
this weekend we miss their voices here
and we honor their memory as being part
of the first let this space be a comfort
to you as your thoughts drift wherever
they need to be may you feel welcome to
participate in any way that brings you a
sense of peace in this moment we have
brought together different elements for
the service there's much music to soothe
some spoken word and poetry prayer and
prose a lovingly curated backdrop and
most importantly they'll be quiet time
and space for you to hold yourself and
one of them in one another gently as you
remember those who have died we have lit
a candle to bring light to each name
some of our sisters left very young
others had more life more decades I
invite you now to breathe in and out
to be fully present in this space with
yourself and one another let us begin
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in Blackwater woods by Mary Oliver look
the trees are turning their own bodies
into pillars of light are giving off the
rich fragrance of cinnamon and
fulfillment the long tapers of cattails
are bursting and floating away over the
blue shoulders of the ponds and every
pond no matter what its name is
is nameless now
every year everything I have ever
learned in my lifetime leads back to
this the fires and the black river of
loss whose other side is salvation whose
meaning none of us will ever know
to live in this world you must be able
to do three things to love what is
mortal to hold it against your bones
knowing your own life depends on it
and when the time comes to let it go to
let it go
you
we will be reading from the first
covenant Psalm knighting I will read the
first line and we'd ask you to respond
in the italicized lines
Lord you have been our dwelling place
and all generations you turn us back to
dust and say turn back Oh mortal ones
you sweep them away they are like a
dream like grass which is renewed in the
morning teach us to number our days that
we may receive a heart of wisdom let the
favor of the Lord our God be upon us and
established the work of our hands
together Oh Lord established the work of
our hands amen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the continuous life by Mark strand
what of the neighborhood homes awash in
a silver light of children hunched in
the bushes watching for signs the
grown-ups will surrender signs that the
irregular pleasures of moving from day
to day of being adrift on the swell of
duty have run their course o parents
confess to your little ones the night is
a long way off and your taste for the
mundane grows tell them your worship of
household chores has barely begun
describe the beauty of shovels and rakes
brooms and mops say there will always be
cooking and cleaning to do that one
thing leads to another which leads to
another explain that you live between
two great darks the first with an ending
the second without one that the luckiest
thing is having been born then you live
in a blur of hours and days months and
years and believe it has meaning despite
the occasional fear you are slipping
away with nothing completed nothing to
prove you existed tell the children to
come inside that your search goes on for
something you lost a name a family album
that fell from its own small matter into
another a piece of the dark that might
have been yours you don't really know
say that each of you tries to keep busy
learning to lean down close and hear the
casual breathing of Earth and feel it's
available Langer come over you wave
after wave sending small tremors of love
through your brief undeniable selves
into your lives and beyond
Oh
my bad
let us remember and give thanks for
those of our classmates who have died
and who blessed us by their presence in
our lives from the class of 1971 karen
Hamady Cynthia Jordan Karen Katzman
Cathy Coonan Ellen the learner
Darrell Pollock
Marcy rosemon
Merle Roth Ruben Christina Zuni dear
latke whinings
from the class of 1972 I needed a Dixon
Maurice Baptiste Edwards Gail Frischmann
Serena Wardlaw Henry
Anya Hilliard
Susan Lifshitz Marjorie Marx Elizabeth
Montgomery Hines
sherry nickels
Pamela Horton Oliva Judy rads dinner
Nevada flip sanika Rosanna Sattler
from the class of 1973 Jocelyn Chang
Jane Curtis Stephanie Hill fish
Lisa Goldberg Christa Hansen Gail
Horowitz Olga Howard Alison Boucher crab
Susan McClure Susan O'Connor Diane poem
darriel Sneed and Deanne Strauss is
elgus daughter lying with us
it's truly been a transformative weekend
to be here with you all I hope you'll
bear with me for a few minutes in this
wonderful ceremony so I can tell you a
little bit more about my mother
my mother lived her early life in Berlin
Germany to understand my mother truly
you had to understand her mother
she was an amazing woman
Lisa Stein hurts as early as 1930
she realized that the family would
eventually need to leave Germany and she
started to plan part of that planning
included hiring a British governess for
my mother and her younger brother so
that
by the time she came to America in
19:36 at the age of 12 she was fluent in
English she had lived learned English in
three years
I read from her Journal 1933 came into
my sheltered middle-class childhood as a
welcome diversion my parents suddenly
preoccupied with daily developments for
the first time more or less abandoned my
brother and me to the care of our kinder
machen only she now stood between me and
independence I still vividly recall the
pleasure I derived by not eating what
she put on my plate by playing
hide-and-go-seek leading the poor girl
to believe me lost and by defying the
bedtime that had been rigidly
established by my mother my brother and
I sensed an air of excitement in the
house
she started school at a Montessori which
was eventually closed by the Nazis when
the Montessori School was ordered closed
shortly after Hitler came to power I was
enrolled in an elementary school run by
the Jewish community of Berlin I was
thrilled this was real school at last
formal classrooms regular recess graves
and above all homework on the way home
from school I passed billboards with
anti-semitic cartoons my good friend
Susie and I were inseparable 12 year
olds in 1936 quite accustomed to being
barred from our favourite parks by signs
proclaiming for Aryans only
by the time we arrived after a six-day
crossing of the Atlantic I was delighted
to step ashore in New York
Susie went to England rather than
America and an active correspondence was
begun
September 1937 dear Suzy I hope you
don't think that I've forgotten you but
since I am in school there's very little
time to write the high school is prema
first class I have the choice of taking
the academic course or the general
course I will take the academic course
because I want to go to college because
of this I will take French and Latin
instead of typing in stenography I was
able to choose between painting and
music I chose music I will also take
English mathematics physics and social
studies that is geography history
politics all mixed together
virginia woolf throat for we think back
through our mothers if we are women
Helen Epstein wrote the book where she
came from about her mother's experiences
in the Holocaust
I always felt protective of my mother
because she had lost so many friends and
family I imagined what it must have been
like because she hardly ever talked
about it she said she didn't remember
Helen Epstein wrote I wore the clothes
my mother made for me read the books she
read valued what she thought good
I shared my life with her for a long
time long after adolescents should have
ruptured the bond between us
I shared her loves her disappointments
and her memories she was the engine
behind my energy my defender when I
needed one my solace when the break
finally came it was brutal we came apart
in a great explosion that required years
to repair
in her last year's my mother lived in a
retirement community in Lexington while
my father was sinking into dementia
it was during that time and while I was
living close by that my mother and I
rejoined we had a standing Tuesday
dinner date
sometimes I picked up my young
granddaughter her great-granddaughter
olaria from daycare and she joined us to
our dinners were times of healing
my father died late in 2013 shortly
after my mother was diagnosed with
cancer her last weeks were a gift we
shared with each other in October 2014 I
stayed with her while she received
hospice care
she dictated these last thoughts to me
as I sat in bed with her and as I knit a
layette for her soon to be born second
granddaughter Nadia
you
see if I could find it
November 2014
I would like my family and friends to
know that I'm grateful for the man I
married and the parents I had
I could not be more appreciative of my
three children and my seven
grandchildren and my one great
grandchild ilaria and my great
grandchild to come
I wish everyone could be as lucky as I
have been in having such a family and
such good friends I am appreciative of
Brookhaven where she was living it has
enriched the last years of my life with
new friendships and activities
I've loved the times we all spent in
Wellfleet I have had a very scattered
career but I enjoyed all phases of of it
teacher administrator lawyer mediator
and writer
it is time for somebody my age to move
on
I hope
that all of you will carry on the values
I hold peace and justice an equal
opportunity
Elga Wasserman she's buried in Grove
Street Cemetery it's a beautiful spot
thank you
[Music]
we remember them please joined for
Responsive reading the words and italics
this is by roland gitelson in the gates
of prayer in the rising of the sun and
in it's going down in the blowing of the
wind and in the chill of winter in the
opening buds and in the rebirth of
spring in the blueness of the sky and in
the warmth of summer in the rustling of
leaves and in the beauty of autumn in
the beginning of the year and when it
ends when we are weary and in need of
strength when we are lost and sick at
heart when we have joys we yearn to
share so long as we live they to show
them so they are now a part of us
throughout the planning of this
celebration we heard from several first
women who could not join us today
because of illness disability or
incapacity some are caregivers
themselves for partners and spouses as
we honor the memory of those who have
died let us also remember those in need
of our support in need of a kind word in
need of a prayer as you let the beauty
and emotion fill your hearts during this
song of healing I invite you to send
your most loving of thoughts to those
who could not be here and pray their
names quietly to yourself
[Music]
to make
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man we are coming to the close of
this service and I'd like to thank
everyone who had a hand and its planning
the committee was hard at work across
many miles but always even as a distance
with love and care in mind thank you as
well to all those behind the scenes who
handled logistics and forgotten details
none of this would have been possible
without your patient touch deep
gratitude to our readers and incredible
musicians Nicoletta
Yoon beautiful Martina you blessed us
thank you truly you gave us balm for our
weary Souls finally to each one of you
gathered here this morning thank you for
coming for being present to each other
while we lifted up the names of Yale's
first women who have died as you journey
out of this space into the throes of
continuing celebration and then back to
your daily lives remember the gift you
were to Yale and trust that you're brave
light and steadfast pursuit of truth
lives on today please know that you are
welcome to stay here as long as you may
need continue to share stories continue
to share your remarkable cells may you
imagine a tomorrow where memories of
your departed sisters rest safe and
sheltered in the warmest of places where
hope is always abundant and sustaining
to you my friends I bid you peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is that brought me safe thus far and
grace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
thank you so much one last invitation if
you had written a remembrance for a
classmate you are welcome to come and
take one candle please watch your step
but we would love these candles to live
in hope in your households thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]